[Musique]
envie de dépaysement le planétarium de
montréal vous invite à partir en orbite
à bord de la station spatiale
internationale
lorsque j'ai vu pour la première fois
les images qu'ils avaient obtenus je me
suis dit ouh ça c'est quelque chose il
faut absolument qu'on est au planétarium
la chance que l'on a au planétarium
c'est de pouvoir vivre une expérience
immersive en groupe
jacky ses collègues s'adresse
directement la caméra ils racontent leur
quotidien et les défis à relever pour
habiter dans l'espace on a vraiment
voulu dans ce projet doit se rapprocher
des astronautes fait ressentir au
spectateur qui était pas un spectateur
mais qui était un membre de l'équipage
ces images ont également été utilisés
pour l'exposition immersive l'infini qui
est toujours à l'affiché au centre d'art
contemporain arsenal à montréal c'était
tellement complexe d'une certaine façon
d'aller chercher ces images là et c'est
un projet qu'on a tourné pendant presque
trois ans à l'intérieur et plus
récemment à l'extérieur de la station
spatiale donc qu'on ramène sur terre il
ya quelque chose de précieux là dedans
et on veut s'assurer que le plus grand
nombre de gens possible puissent vivre
cette expérience loc
le planétarium nous invite à prendre un
peu de hauteur et regarder la vie
terrestre autrement la station spatiale
et la planète terre ce sont nos deux
espaces pour la vie c'est les deux seuls
espaces qui existe dans l'univers où les
humains peuvent vivre pour le moment ça
nous permet nous de se dire notre
planète il faut aussi en prendre soin et
la protéger parce que c'est un plus gros
vaisseau spatial mais qui est tout aussi
fragile voyageurs stellaire la vie en
orbite nous amène à l'intérieur de la
station spatiale alors que le prochain
film qui sera présenté à partir de 2022
nous permettra de sortir dans l'espace
avec une caméra placée au bout du bras
canadien et ciney bien alexandre
chartier radio-canada mourir